bevor ich den ersten tagesordnungspunkt
aufrufe müssen wir noch einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag
behandeln die fraktion der cdu/csu hat
beantragt die heutige tagesordnung um
eine debatte zum völkerrechtswidrigen
russischen angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
zu erweitern
dieser soll
dieser soll als erster
tagesordnungspunkt mit einer zeit von 68
minuten vorgesehen wären dann ist dazu
das wort gewünscht
märz britischer
auch präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren seit drei wochen
beschweren uns diese schrecklichen
bilder aus der ukraine
und heute morgen haben wir eine rede des
chronischen staatspräsidenten gehört
wir haben zu beginn dieser woche die
mehrheitsfraktionen dieses hauses
gebeten im anschluss an diese rede eine
aussprache im deutschen bundestag zu
ermöglichen über den stand dieses
schrecklichen krieges
sie haben das mit ihrer mehrheit
abgelehnt der bundeskanzler sie haben
vor drei wochen an dieser stelle vor
knapp drei wochen eine eindrucksvolle
regierungserklärung
es hat in der zwischenzeit einen
sondergipfel der staats und
regierungschefs der europäischen union
gegeben es gibt in wenigen tagen einen
sondergipfel der staats und
regierungschefs der nato
und nach dieser rede heute morgen von
staatspräsident selensky wäre es doch
jetzt genau zu dieser minute der
richtige zeitpunkt einmal eine
zwischenbilanz zu ziehen die frage zu
stellen wo stehen wir haben wir das
richtig gemacht gibt es möglicherweise
entscheidungen die nach korrigiert
werden müssen stehen wir eigentlich
heute als bundesrepublik deutschland an
der richtigen stelle wenn es um diesen
punkten
sie haben
wir haben gestern in der debatte die wir
hier gehabt haben über eine stunde
schweigend auf der regierungsbank es ist
heute nachmittag führen wir eine
diskussion über die menschenrechtslage
in der ukraine und frau präsidentin mit
verlaub sie sagen uns heute morgen wie
der beirat der kleinen forscher besetzt
werden soll
meine damen und herren und wann denn
wenn nicht jetzt eine diskussion eine
zwischenbilanz eine frage an uns selbst
ob wir
obwohl wir nicht
vielleicht und wenn ist und wenn es nur
darum geht uns noch einmal selbst zu
vergewissern wo wir stehen unter
bundeskanzler ich finde dass die
bundesrepublik deutschland anspruch
darauf hat von ihnen heute morgen zu
erfahren wie sie die lage sehen und
welche schlussfolgerungen daraus zu
ziehen haben wenn sie allerdings spd
grüne und fdp mit ihrer meinung hier
eine mehrheitsentscheidung durchsetzen
dann will ich ihm von unserer seite aus
nur sagen dies stößt ausdrücklich auf
unseren widerspruch und unsere
missbilligung wir sind damit nicht
einverstanden wie sie das heute morgen
werden
katja mast redet für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsident sind meine
sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen
präsident selensky
hat gerade eben eine sehr eindringliche
rede gehalten
dafür
dafür danke ich ihm ausdrücklich
wir die ampelkoalition
sind überzeugt dass die worte des
ukrainischen präsidenten für sich stehen
sie haben es verdient für sich
wahrgenommen zu werden
die menschen in der ukraine
leiden seit dem 24
februar unter schrecklicher kriegsgewalt
durch putins truppen sie kämpfen sie
leiten sie haben angst
sie fliehen
familien werden auseinandergerissen und
menschen sterben täglich und fallen in
diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
mit diesem völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
auf die ukraine hat der russische
präsident
grundlegende
internationale normen und werte mit
füßen getreten
deswegen hat der bundeskanzler
unmittelbar darum gebeten am sonntag den
februar vor dem deutschen bundestag eine
regierungserklärung
abzugeben
er hat diese zeitenwende
umfassend erläutert und antworten darauf
gegeben im anschluss hat es hier im
deutschen bundestag eines sehr lange
ausführliche aussprache gegeben das war
angemessen
noch keine 24 stunden her hat cdu und
csu der tagesordnung für diese
sitzungswoche hier im bundestag
zugestimmt
zwei aktuelle studien zur lage und
ist er
ungefähr fünf stunden später ohne neue
sachlage macht die union eine rolle
rückwärts und beantragte erweiterung der
tagesordnung jetzt müssen wir die
debatte leider führen während menschen
in der ukraine sterben sind wir
gefordert wir sind gefordert alles zu
tun ihre lage zu verbessern und die
flüchtlinge gut bei uns aufzunehmen
darum geht es in dieser situation
und daran arbeitet die gesamte
bundesregierung und die gesamte
koalition in dieser situation mit
unserem bundeskanzler oder
die
kollegin sie müssen bis zum schluss
komme zum schluss die
bundesaußenminister in annalena baerbock
hat es gestern wie ich finde sehr
treffend gesagt in dieser lage ist zu
hören eine echte stärke zu hören und das
wort stehen lassen ich finde das ist ein
würdiger rahmen für diese rede
frau kollegin werden diesen antrag daher
ablehnen
jan korte hat jetzt das wort für die
fraktion die linke
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich muss jetzt zunächst einmal
feststellen dass sich die empörung der
ampelkoalition dem wunsch in dieser
situation eine debatte zu führen und zu
hören was die bundesregierung zu sagen
hat absolut lächerlich und genuss sind
macht das war vieles auf das land eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte
absolut deplatziert und
ich möchte schon feststellen so leid es
mir tut dass meine fraktion in diesem
fall den antrag der cdu csu ausdrücklich
unterstützt findet das mindeste dass wir
heute ihre positionierung auch zu den
fragen die eben der ukrainische
präsident hier aufgerufen hat dass sie
die hier daten und die sind ja
ich kann ja sehen dass die
bundesregierung ihrer ganzen pracht wenn
man so will ich hier heute versammelt
ist und da sie ja auch professionelle
politik machen kann ich erwarten dass
jetzt die gleich ans pult gehen und die
hier spontan diese debatte führen können
das jetzt möglich sein in diese fragen
ich möchte zum zweiten anmerken warum
ich das wirklich für völlig richtig
halte dass wir darüber diskutieren und
katja mast wir hatten eine debatte unter
den parlamentarischen geschäftsführern
über die tagesordnung sehr wohl und es
gab dem antrag des kollegen frei hier
diese debatte zu führen die form einer
fraktion ausdrücklich unterstützt worden
ist so ist die sachlage gerät
unterstützt mit dem was er sagt so herr
so wird es und was ich auch schon
kolleginnen gehandelt was ich auch schon
sehr interessant finde also ausgerechnet
die frau zu fahren fdp und grüne sie und
wir waren ja noch von 150 tagen in einer
anderen situation wo sie grundsätzlich
mit uns dafür gestritten haben dass die
bundesregierung hier rechenschaft
ablegen solchen fragen und das ist auf
einmal vorbei sind ist verlor ohne
letzter punkt
letzter punkt den ich ansprechen möchte
ist sie kriegen das noch nun mit man
muss seinen kindern erklären dass wir
auf einmal wieder krieg in europa die
leute sprechen darüber es gibt große
angst und wir sind eine situation wo sie
herr bundeskanzler das größte
militarisierung und auf rüstungsprogramm
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland angekündigt haben so ist es
gewesen wovon ihre fraktion bis auf die
erste reihe nicht nur was wusste er ist
das mindeste dass wir darüber
diskutieren die ihre pläne dazu sind
sowohl das mindeste über 100 milliarden
euro sonderformen dazu steht und
abschließend tage ich als christin doch
wirklich kein zacken aus der krone
werden wird hier diese debatte führen
und ich will ich schon sagen also auch
diese sicherlich empörung wird dass die
oppositionsfraktion er einen antrag
stellt ist wirklich lächerlich da will
ich nochmal eins sagen sie müssen wir
aufpassen dass sie nicht nach 100 tagen
schon so arrogant sind wie andere nach
16 jahren um das auch immer alles gesagt
zu wort gemeldet hat sich jetzt noch die
kollegin britta haßelmann für bündnis 90
die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
finde es sehr bedauerlich dass dem
parlament heute morgen nicht gelungen
ist in gänze
die rede des präsidenten der ukraine
einfach auf sich wirken zu lassen
und in der parlamentarischen debatte
so
haben sie jetzt genug geschrieben da
hinten kommen sie doch nach vorne
meine damen und herren ich fange noch
mal an denn offenbar hat der vorsitzende
der cdu/csu-fraktion
diese situation genutzt um seiner
fraktion so richtig einzuheizen
dass man wollte aus der lage was machen
muss ich habe deshalb gesagt ich
bedauere es dass das parlament nicht die
kraft gefunden hat der rede des
präsidenten
der ukraine mit würde und muss mit
respekt einfach zuzuhören und die
debatten und die debatten
sowie gemeinsam mit ihrer fraktion
vereinbart gestern mittag als das
parlament hier seine sitzung begonnen
hat hat herr merz herr freiherr dobrindt
ich kann sie jetzt alle aufzählen haben
der tagesordnung die wir vereinbart
haben gestern eine debatte zu führen zur
lage des angriffskriegs putin auf die
ukraine und heute eine weitere debatte
zu führen zugestimmt es ist so sie haben
gestern der tagesordnung zugestimmt und
vor raich
zur wahrheit gehört auf
und zur wahrheit gehört auch und das ist
eigentlich der situation unangemessen
ich habe lange überlegt ob wir für die
fraktion überhaupt hier reden weil wir
es einfach unmöglich finden was die
cdu/csu aus dieser situation macht meine
damen und herren
bis zum beginn der sitzung dieser
sitzung jetzt bis zum beginn der
würdigen rede die wir alle respektvoll
aufgenommen haben des präsidenten der
ukraine war die cdu/csu nicht in der
lage uns zu sagen
ob sie eine geschäftsordnungsdebatte
wünscht oder nicht das wohl man sich
offen halten meine damen und herren das
können im parlament so machen ja aber da
sieht man doch was hier gesucht wird
nicht die debatte in der sache zur
legitimierung und erwerb der wert
es enttäuscht sie
dass sie nicht in der lage sind die
auseinandersetzung in der sache zu
suchen wenn wir heute
wir heute zudem nicht irgendwas im mein
garten zeitpunkt darüber sprechen denn
das werden wir später an torfrau hatte
man sie sind einer der täter sie müssten
bitte faxen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herr baumann hat sich gemeldet und herr
dürr hat sich gemeldet ich gebe herrn
baumann das wort und ein handy
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
sie haben jetzt die bewegenden worte des
ukrainischen präsidenten gehört und was
macht dieses parlament heraus die cdu
hat der tagesordnung zugestimmt jetzt
auf einmal will sie ablehnen wenn sie
wirklich konsistent das verfolgt hätten
hätten sie der tagesordnung nicht
zustimmen dürfen sie haben ja ein
klamauk draus gemacht dass es der sache
völlig unangemessen herr merz
ansonsten haben wir hier tag für tag und
sitzungswoche für sitzungswoche themen
die wichtig sind die wichtiger sind aber
heute haben wir ein thema da geht es um
krieg und frieden in diesem haus und
wenn wir dann einen staatspräsidenten
haben aus einem land das angegriffen
worden ist und wenn die bekundung in
eine richtung sind wie bewegend aßlar
und wie mitnimmt und wie wichtig da
unsere reaktion darauf ist oder machen
wir gar nicht so machen jetzt impfschutz
gesetz oder das kann auch nicht sagen
meine damen und herren wir müssen die
debatte wenigstens aufsetzen und der
bundeskanzler muss sich hier zu wort
melden und sagen wo es lang gehen soll
in reaktion auf den präsidenten das
verlangt der respekt
christian dürr für die fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kollegen und kollegen ich könnte jetzt
sagen herr kollege merz dass der
deutsche bundestag anders als sie es
gerade dargestellt hat in dieser woche
selbstverständlich mehrfach über den
furchtbaren angriffskrieg in der ukraine
sprechen wird und nicht nur der deutsche
bundestag im plenum in seinen
ausschüssen und wir als demokraten auch
in der öffentlichkeit ich könnte an
dieser stelle anführen herr kollege merz
dass das britische unterhaus und der us
amerikanische kongress danach keine
parteipolitische aussprache geführt hat
über die rede des präsidenten
und
könnt ihr kollege merz noch einmal
betonen dass was die kolleginnen und
kollegen hasselmann und
masters gesagt haben
ich könnte an dieser stelle aus führen
dass in kenntnis der rede des
präsidenten der ukraine heute morgen
ihre fraktion gestern dieser
tagesordnung zugestimmt haben herr merz
ich könnte unterstreichen
dass sie all das wussten vor dieser
debatte sie wussten es gestern morgen
sie wussten es gestern nachmittag herr
merz die kronzeugen die gerade für sie
hier gesprochen haben das spricht bände
aus meiner sicht ich teile einer
auffassung herr merz ja wir hätten
sicherlich das hätte ihre fraktion
beantragen können eine unterbrechung der
sitzung machen können bevor wir in die
reguläre tagesordnung einsteigen aber
herr merz das was sie gerade gemacht
haben gerade vor dem hintergrund der
einigkeit der demokraten in diesem haus
was diesen angriffskrieg betrifft liebe
kollegen kollegen vor diesem hintergrund
herr merz war das ein unwürdiges
schauspiel was ihre fraktionen heute
morgen auftritt ein unwürdiges
schauspiel
[Applaus]
herr kollege merz was die bewertung
dieses angriffskrieges betrifft sind
unsere fraktionen die fraktion der ampel
koalition ihrer fraktion in wahrheit
nicht auseinander umso mehr umso mehr
herr kollege merz fordere ich sie auf
weil wir werden diese debatten
mutmaßlich leider in den kommenden tagen
und wochen öfter haben fordere ich sie
auf solche parteipolitischen spielchen
zu unterlassen das macht keinen sinn
herr merz geschadet den gemeinsamen
anliegen
meine aufgabe ist es jetzt zur
abstimmung zu kommen und ich will dazu
etwas erklären was in unserer
geschäftsordnung dazu vorgesehen ist es
ist richtig dass wir gestern die
tagesordnung für drei tage festgelegt
haben gleichwohl es ist es recht
einzelner fraktionen die tagesordnung
ändern zu wollen das ist auch
rechtzeitig eingereicht und geschehen
zweiten
zweitens unserer geschäftsordnung sieht
nach paragraf 126 der geschäftsordnung
des bundestages vor dass eine solche
beschlussfassung ohne vorlagen mit zwei
drittel mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
gefasst werden müsste darauf weise ich
sie hin wenn ich jetzt zur abstimmung
komme und frage sie wer stimmt für den
aussetzungsantrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich
herzlichen dank damit ist dem
aussetzungsantrag nicht mit der
notwendigen mehrheit zugestimmt
zugestimmt haben die fraktionen der
union die fdp und die linke dagegen
gestimmt haben die fraktionen von spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
ich rufe jetzt auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 6 a bis e hier geht
es um die beratung mehrerer vorlagen
betreffend der einführung einer
impfpflicht gegen das saft auf zwei
büros
für die aussprache sind 68 minuten
vorgesehen und ich weise auf die
vereinbarungen hin dass die reden der
kolleginnen und kollegen deren rede
wunsch nicht berücksichtigt werden kann
zu protokoll genommen wird sie wissen
dass wir hier eine mischung aus
fraktions und gruppen anträgen haben und
dass deswegen die reedereien folge und
die redezeiten anders festgelegt worden
sind als üblicherweise das führt auch
dazu dass wir beim aufruf der
rednerinnen und redner nicht die
fraktionen mit benennen sondern
gegebenenfalls die gruppen oder eben die
fraktion wenn es sich um einen
fraktionsantrag handelt die erste
rednerin des teitge behrens von der
gruppe behrends und andere
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen stellen sie
sich vor wir hätten heute bereits eine
impfquote von 90 prozent dann stecken
wir nicht fest in der größten
infektionswelle seit beginn der pandemie
deutschland hat
deutschland hat europaweit die höchste
instanz einzelne krankenhäuser müssen
wieder operationen verschieben höchste
anspannung und belastung für das
personal was für ein trauerspiel
wieder und wieder müssen wir erkennen
das virus ist nicht berechenbar es
reicht eben nicht aus nur auf die
aktuelle situation zu reagieren wir
müssen grundlegend die voraussetzungen
dafür schaffen dass wir nicht noch
einmal von einer weiteren
infektionswelle überrollt werden und
darum setze ich mich gemeinsam mit
236 kolleginnen und kollegen aus vier
fraktionen für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht für alle erwachsenen in
deutschland ein
wir wollen unsere gesellschaft und unser
gesundheitswesen vor überlastung
schützen
dazu müssen wir eine hohe
grundimmunisierung aufbauen und wir
wissen seit langem und können dies in
anderen ländern sehen je mehr menschen
durch impfung vor einer corona infektion
geschützt sind umso weniger menschen
erkrankten schwer umso schneller können
wir zu einem gesellschaftlichen leben
ohne freiheitseinschränkende
schutzmaßnahmen zurückkehren danach
sehnen wir uns alle und das ist dringend
nötig für unsere kinder und jugendlichen
für unsere wirtschaft für alle die tag
und nacht um das leben von schwer
erkrankten menschen bringen und auch
sich um pflegebedürftige kümmern
so hat die welle zu kommen müssen wir
eine hohe impfquote bis zum herbst
erreicht haben durch informationen
aufklärung beratung und eben auch eine
impf nachweispflicht wie auch
kontrolliert wird unser gesetzentwurf
ist gut begründet und solider
ausgestaltet mit ihm werben wir hier und
heute dafür gemeinsam diesen echten weg
der vorsorge zu beschreiten ich wende
mich an alle verantwortungsbewussten
demokratinnen und demokraten im
deutschen bundestag an die
nachdenklichen und die unentschlossenen
an die denen es wichtig ist die
impfskepsis noch besser zu beraten zu
informieren und zu überzeugen
andy die ernsthaft für den herbst
vorsorgen wollen weil sie das gemeinwohl
im blick haben lassen sie uns gemeinsam
den konsens suchen für einen
nachhaltigen weg diese pandemie unter
kontrolle zu bringen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union wenn sie ihren antrag zur
impfpflicht vorsorge nicht heute sondern
vor vier monaten eingebracht hätten dann
müssten sie heute im angesicht der
aktuellen dramatischen infektions lage
zu der erkenntnis kommen es braucht den
impf mechanismus wie sie es nennen jetzt
denn nur dann werden diejenigen die
heute noch nicht geimpft sind die
notwendige grund immunität bis zum
herbst erreicht haben und darum bitte
warten sie nicht länger ab sehen sie der
realität ins auge gehen sie mit uns den
weg der vernunft und der vorsorge die
unserem gemeinwohl dienen vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
sepp müller spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir stehen
noch alle unter dem tiefen eindruck der
heutigen rede des staatspräsidenten
selensky aus der ukraine und er sprach
von einer mauer und liebe ampel parteien
anscheinend haben sie eine mauer in dem
kopf wenn wir eine debatte nach dieser
rede über die impfpflicht in deutschland
im bundestag führen das geht gar nicht
menschen sterben
bomben fliegen auf theater wo kinder
schutz suchen und wir führen in diesem
haus eine debatte zur impfpflicht
und wenn wir den bundeskanzler sehen der
gott sei dank heute da ist dann wäre das
das mindeste gewesen herr bundeskanzler
dass sie dazu eine regierungserklärung
abgeben
ohne anstand ohne würde und ohne respekt
dem staatspräsidenten gegenüber sein
gesagt es stehen zu lassen ohne eine
antwort zu geben das ist diesem
parlament geschätzte frau präsidentin
unwürdig und
wenn wir uns die
situation in der ukraine anschauen
dann ist das nicht nur bedrückend
sondern dann ist diese situation für uns
alle auch schwer in worte zu fassen
und deswegen ist das vielleicht auch die
sprachlosigkeit der ampel weil sie in
vielen punkten keine mehrheit haben ein
kollege sprach das an wie wird in die
ausgestaltung des sondervermögens 100
milliarden euro aussehen wie ist denn
ihre meinung und die kollegen von den
grünen sprach von parteipolitik wenn ich
die grüne jugend aus berlin in sozialen
medien leser die sagen für 100
milliarden euro könnte man 20 milliarden
hamster kaufen dann ist das ungehörig
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren und
parteipolitik und
schauen wir uns dann auch diese ampel an
dann hat sie nicht nur bei diesen großen
staatspolitischen herausforderungen
keine mehrheit sondern auch bei der
debatte die der bundeskanzler gewünscht
hat nämlich beim thema impfpflicht man
muss doch ganz deutlich sagen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt ist die impfpflicht
tot es gibt keine mehrheit in diesem
haus für eine allgemeine impfpflicht ab
18 und wir als unionsfraktion die
während der orientierungs debatte
vom professor lauterbach als
gesundheitsminister per tweet beschimpft
wurde während unsere räder vorne standen
dass wir das parteipolitisch
ausschlachten würden wir haben uns
gedanken gemacht mit expertinnen und
experten gesprochen und einen vorschlag
gemacht der eint und nicht ihre
vorschläge dieses parlament meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
und wir haben mit 197 abgeordneten einen
antrag der mehrheitsfähig ist und
deswegen bitte schließen sie sich auch
an denn wir wollen drei dinge erstens
ein im register damit wir überhaupt
wissen wer geimpft ist und dadurch eine
impfkampagne auf den weg bringen können
zweitens einen 14-tägigen bericht der
bundesregierung insbesondere
gesundheitsministers damit er das nicht
immer bei anne will erklären muss
sondern auch mal dem parlament erklären
kann und drittens meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren ein vorsorge
mechanismus wenn eines dieser papiere zu
dem entschluss kommt dass eine tödliche
variante da ist so tödlich wie delta und
so anstrengend wie omikron dann würden
wir mit einem mechanismus auch eine
impfpflicht nach alterskohorten
entsprechend scharf schalten all das ist
ein einigen der vorschlag der liegt auf
den tisch und da bitten wir um
zustimmung
jetzt spricht alles für die afg fraktion
[Musik]
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren die
vorliegenden anträge für eine
impfpflicht den verschiedenen spielarten
sind das produkt von verbohrter
besessenheit und ignoranter tatsachen
verweigerung
deutschland steht diese absurden und
anachronistischen debatte wieder einmal
als europäischer sonderling da selbst
unsere nachbarn in österreich haben das
vorhaben impfpflicht vorerst ausgesetzt
die impfpflicht ist auch falschen
tatsachenbehauptung aufgebaut dass eine
impfung
andere wirksam vor ansteckung schützt
und die ausbreitung des virus dämpft
sind fake news sie sind falsch das muss
sogar das robert-koch-institut zu geben
der versprochene schutz vor schweren
verläufen es ebenfalls fragwürdig
angesichts des wachsenden anteils von
geimpften und gebucht hatten auf der
intensivstation
eine das gesundheitssystem gefährdende
überlastung der krankenhäuser gab es nie
es gibt sie nicht sie droht auch nicht
das hat im übrigen der
gesundheitsminister und freiwillig
zugeben müssen eine impfpflicht ist auch
nicht erforderlich um lockdown im herbst
zu verhindern lok downs verhindert man
in dem die regierung keine verhängt so
einfach ist dass die nutzlosigkeit und
schädlichkeit von lok sollte sich
inzwischen herumgesprochen haben dagegen
sind aber die potenziell nebenwirkung
der mma und vector impfstoffe weitaus
schwerer und weiter verbreitet als
ursprünglich behauptet wann wird darüber
eigentlich mal in diesem hause
gesprochen
die argumente für eine impfpflicht waren
von anfang an schwach und sie sind auch
inzwischen wie ein kartenhaus in sich
zusammen gefallen es gibt keine legitime
und verfassungsrechtlich zulässige
rechtfertigung für die einführung einer
impfpflicht gegen kuwait 19 als selbst
nicht auf 18 850 impfpflicht aus als
vorrat oder einrichtungs bezogen eine
allgemeine impfpflicht verletzt zentrale
grundrechte wie menschenwürde das recht
auf leben und körperliche unversehrtheit
und das recht auf die glaubens und
gewissensfreiheit
die verhältnismäßigkeit einen derart
schweren grundrechtseingriff
legitimieren würde ist nicht gegeben die
impfpflicht ist nicht geeignet um die
angestrebten ziele zu erreichen sie ist
auch nicht erforderlich da als andere
und viel mildere therapien und maßnahmen
gibt und sie ist auch nicht angemessen
dem staat ist nicht erlaubt leben und
gesundheit einiger bürger zu gefährden
um andere bürger zu schützen die
begründung eine impfpflicht sei
notwendig um eine überlastung der
krankenhäuser zu verhindern ist nicht
nur falsch sie ist gefährlich nach
dieser pseudo logik könnte man menschen
künftig allen möglichen
behandlungen aufnötigen von der pflicht
medikation von bluthochdruck gefährdeten
bis hin zu zwangsdiät für übergewichtige
und zur begründung reicht ein politisch
selbst hergestellter kapazitätsengpass
ich hoffe sie merken selbst wie absurd
das ist die impfpflicht ist ein akt der
entrechtung sie erniedrigt millionen
menschen von souveränen mit freiheits
und abwehr rechten ausgestatteten
individuen zu befehlsempfänger und
objekten staatlicher willkür
sie treibt millionen mehr sie treibt
millionen menschen in gewissenskonflikte
und existenzielle nöte sehr geehrte
kollegen von regierungsfraktionen union
die sie einen der vorliegenden
impfpflicht anträge unterstützen sie
reiten ein totes pferd bitte steigen sie
ab ziehen sie diese anträge zurück und
lassen sie uns gemeinsam den irrweg der
einrichtungs bezogenen pflege
impfpflicht so schnell wie möglich
beenden so schnell wie möglich paroli
haben sie im schlussdrittel ist in
diesen schweren zeiten nicht leisten auf
starrsinn und rechthaberei die
gesellschaft mit einer impfpflicht noch
weiter zu spalten für die es weder
medizinisch noch rechtlich eine
begründung gibt ich bedanke mich
für die gruppe wolfgang kubicki und
andere spricht jetzt der kollege manuel
höferlin
ja das war präsidentin meine damen und
herren
wer eine impfpflicht einführen würde er
muss erklären wozu diese genau führen
soll und die frage die sich mir stellen
sind schaffen wir mit der impfung eine
herdenimmunität die antwort ist nein
schöpfen schützt die impfung sicher vor
ansteckung nein schützt die impfung vor
ansteckung anderer nein
verhindern wir mit der impfpflicht eine
infektionswelle im kommenden herbst die
antwort ist nein keine frage meine damen
und herren die impfung schützt mich
wahrscheinlich vor einem schweren
verlauf und ziemlich sicher vor dem tod
deswegen habe ich mich auch impfen
lassen wussten lassen meine familie hat
das gemacht und ich empfehle es mit
nachdruck jedem zu machen und dafür zu
werben
daraus resultiert aber nicht die pflicht
zu einer impfung diese pflicht
einzuführen ohne eine antwort auf die
frage zu finden
ob es nicht die mildere omikron variante
dazu führt andere bewertungsmaßstäbe zu
anzulegen die halte ich für
problematisch
meine damen und herren mittlerweile
haben sich die infektionszahlen auch von
den krankenhaus behandlungen von der
belegung der intensivstationen
abgekoppelt und die prognosen manche
dass die intensivstationen nun voll
laufen oder noch anders dass sie es
nicht tun wenn wir jetzt eine
impfpflicht einführen das entbehrt jeder
grundlage
keine europäische demokratie hat aktuell
die pflicht zur impfung selbst
österreich hat sie gerade wieder außer
vollzug gesetzt mit der
nachvollziehbaren begründung unter der
omicron variante ergeben sie keinen sinn
mehr
man lernt herren ja wir müssen die wohl
warengruppen schützen aber nicht vor
sich selbst denn zu behaupten für deren
schutz bräuchte es eine impfpflicht das
trägt nicht diejenigen die bis jetzt
geimpft sind die wollen sich
wahrscheinlich nicht impfen lassen und
vielleicht tragen sie auch lieber eine
maske um sich zu schützen das ist ihre
entscheidung und übrigens ist das auch
ihr gutes recht das zu tun nach zwei
jahren pandemie sollten wir den menschen
aber wieder eigene entscheidungen zu
trauern für staatliche bevormundung ist
weder zeit noch rechtlicher raum und
unsere verfassung meiner und herren
sieht das schlicht nicht vor
statt zwang wäre eigentlich das gebot
der stunde doch die angekündigten
impfkampagnen die mit viel geld
finanziert und entweder verpufft sind
oder noch auf ihre umsetzung warten
dazu machen wir einen amt in unserem
antrag konkrete vorschläge und lassen
sie mich noch einmal klarstellen die
entscheidung über die eigene gesundheit
um das eigene leben liegt am ende immer
noch bei jedem selbst
in der verantwortung von uns im
deutschen bundestag liegt es aber
hingegen bei anderen erkenntnisse auch
andere wege zu gehen was im letzten
herbst noch gegolten hat ist nach der
heutigen erkenntnislage vielleicht
anders und deshalb lassen sie uns heute
und im weiteren verlauf offen und
ehrlich diskutieren nicht nur darüber
was als nötig empfunden wird sondern was
wirklich bürgerinnen bürgern hilft und
was rechtlich möglich ist herzlichen
dank
der kollege dr andré ullmann hat jetzt
das wort für die gruppe janitschek
ullmann und andere
sehr verehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren
mehrheitlich in diesem parlament sind
wir uns ja einig wir wollen das
gesundheitssystem vor überlastung
schützen und diese belastung können wir
nur schützen indem wir die
krankheitslast
reduzieren und eine krankheit was wir
nur dann reduziert wenn wir eine gewisse
grundimmunisierung in unserer
bevölkerung haben und das ist das
fundament ist wir brauchen unser weg ist
aber ein anderer ein ziel ist relativ
klar ausgesprochen unser will ich das
gesetz des entwurfs sagt klar wir
vertrauen den menschen eine richtige
entscheidung zu treffen nur um diese
richtige entscheidung zu treffen bedarf
es einer professionellen guten
aufklärung und deshalb setzen wir uns ja
auch dafür ein eine verpflichtende
aufklärung für diejenigen in den weg zu
bringen auf den weg zu bringen damit sie
eine gute entscheidung machen können
damit sie weniger ängste und
unsicherheiten haben diese
verpflichtende beratung meine damen und
herren ist ein milderes mittel im
vergleich zu einer impfpflicht denn eine
impfpflicht darf nur eine ultima ratio
sein und nicht eine sofortige umsetzung
dieser situation
wir wollen die impflücken schließen vor
allem die impflücken der wohlhabenden
personen und das bis zum herbst denn ein
ziel sollte uns eigentlich einigen wir
müssen die wohlhabenden menschen
schützen vor krankenhausaufenthalte die
wir letztes jahr vorletztes jahr erlebt
war mit 19 und dieses gesetz würde ein
gesamtkonzept der pandemie bekämpfung
auch gut hineinpassen unser
gesetzentwurf baute brücken brücke mit
den anderen anträgen die wir hier im
bundestag haben wir wollen und lade ich
alle
demokraten in diesem parlament auf
mitzuarbeiten dass wir eine lösung für
unser land bekommen dass wir weihnachten
dieses jahr mit unseren mit unserem
freund so feiern können wie wir es
gewohnt sind denn das haben wir heute in
der hand wie wir heute etwas nicht
ändern dann sind wir verloren und haben
wieder ein weihnachten wir setzten zwei
jahre erlebt haben und das wollen wir
eigentlich verhindern und deshalb frage
bitte ich um die zusammenarbeit und
spätere zustimmung zu diesem gesetz
herzliches danke danke schön
[Applaus]
unser kollege dr robert habeck hat jetzt
das wort für die gruppe behrens und
andere
und sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
rede also für die allgemeine impfpflicht
mit 18 und ich will das auch gleich
begründen zuvor will ich gerne eine
anmerkung machen dass wir hier
diskutieren und dass wir uns für den weg
entschieden haben gruppenanträge zu
gehen mit der gruppenanträge zugehen
entbindet uns natürlich nicht von der
pflicht eine lösung zu finden am ende
wäre das schlimmste wenn es keine lösung
geben würde ja es ist eine moralisch
komplexe abwägung die wir jetzt alle
vornehmen müssen aber ich will
ausdrücklich sagen die individuelle
gewissensentscheidung kann nicht dazu
führen dass wir der verantwortung zum
wohle der menschen in diesem lande am
ende nicht gerecht werden
so die sich eben kurz darüber
ausgetauscht ob man hinter eine debatte
zu kleine oder nicht führen können hätte
man diese debatte geführt hätte man
überhaupt den machen über krisen geführt
gäbe es einen übergang zu dieser debatte
nämlich die frage und das ist die frage
die beantwortet werden muss tun wir
alles um vorsorge zu treffen die
vorsorge frage ist die frage wie wir mit
den krisen umgehen und vorsorge bedeutet
denken in eventualitäten was kann alles
noch passieren diese frage nicht der
status quo nicht die omikron variante
steht im mittelpunkt der debatte sondern
tun wir alles dafür dieses land und ihre
menschen zu schützen vor wieder großen
freiheitseinschränkung und wenn man das
wenn man das sich klar macht worum es
eigentlich geht dann muss man
feststellen erstens das virus ist
typischer lisa und mutanten reicher als
wir es uns vor zwei oder drei jahren
überhaupt haben träumen lassen 21
menschen sind aus guten oder schlechten
gründen widerwilliger sich zu schützen
vor diesem virus und damit kriegen wir
nicht den grundschutz in der
gesellschaft
viertens die freiheits abwägung bzw die
als interpretation der wenigen darf
nicht zur permanenten
freiheitseinschränkung der vielen führen
das kann nicht der deal sein
wir schwimmen also bei der frage darüber
ab ob wir am ende wieder an ein regime
einkehren wollen dass das kulturelle
leben leben zum erlahmen bringt das
kinder und menschen die ist nicht zu
dicke haben in jeder situation zwingt
das wieder massive freiheits einbußen
und unter untersagung des öffentlichen
lebens bzw gesellschaftlichen lebens
einkehrt das müssen wir doch mal
durchbrechen das müssen wir doch
verhindern darum geht es doch im kern
ich würde dir eine an ihrer stelle sagen
wir haben es satt die menschen in diesem
land haben es hat bringen wir diese
pandemie endlich hinter uns erledigen
wir das virus und kehren gedankt zur
freiheit zurück ja es wäre besser
gewesen menschen hätten sich freiwillig
in großer zahl impfen lassen das wäre
natürlich die bessere lösung gewesen
aber das hier ist nicht getan haben in
bindet dieses haus und uns alle nicht
von der verantwortung dafür zu sorgen
dass wir wieder ein freies leben in
deutschland führen könnten nicht mehr
einschränken
deswegen deswegen stimmen die für einen
antrag der die herde immunität in
deutschland hoch hält für dass wir
wieder das virus besiegen können
dankeschön
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen sehr geehrter herr habe ich sie
haben vollkommen recht wir hätten schon
viel viel früher hier über dieses thema
in diesem plenum debattieren müssen und
dass wir das eben nicht getan haben dass
wir nicht früher darüber debattiert
haben das lag an bundeskanzler scholz
das lag an bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach die noch ende letzten jahres
vollmundig bekundet haben sie seien für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht haben aber
nicht die kraft besessen hier in diesem
hohen haus einen kompromissfähigen
antrag einzubringen genau das ist das
problem
und deshalb haben wir jetzt die
situation wie wir sie haben sie haben
den weg der gruppenanträge gewählt mit
unsicheren mehrheiten sehr langsam und
wissen letztendlich nicht wie die ganze
sache ausgeht und wenn jetzt immer
argumentiert wird wir müssten doch jetzt
alle an einem strang ziehen dann
erklären sie doch mal wie dieser strang
aussieht und wir haben als einzige
fraktion hier gesagt die unterbreiten
einen kompromissvorschlag wir sind fast
200 kolleginnen und kollegen in der
unionsfraktion und wir haben genau das
getan was die aufgabe der ampel gewesen
wäre nämlich einen kompromissvorschlag
für dieses komplexe thema zu
unterbreiten und deshalb höre ich immer
in den letzten tagen es wäre ja schön
wenn man sich hier im hohen hause
einigen würde wenn man einen kompromiss
finden würde ich sage ihnen ganz klar
dieser kompromiss liegt seit wochen auf
dem tisch ist der im vorsorge
mechanismus unserer fraktion liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deshalb kann ich ihnen auch nur noch
mal sagen es geht hier bei diesem thema
nicht um pauschale lösungen wir haben
ein sehr komplexes problem wir haben
geänderte rahmenbedingungen die haben
mit der omicron variante höhere
infektionszahlen aber viel viel milde
verläufe und deshalb wäre es völlig
falsch mit einer pauschalen lösung wie
hier suggeriert wird also alle sollen
sich impfen lassen im fis gut ja aber
alle menschen zu zwingen sich impfen
lassen wird nicht dazu führen dass wir
das problem lösen das liegt erstens
daran bei dir nicht differenzieren bei
dem antrag im fisch für alle deshalb
haben wir gesagt als unionsfraktion wir
brauchen einen in vorsorge mechanismus
das heißt wir schauen uns an haben wir
überhaupt eine ordentliche
datengrundlage genau das doch das
kernproblem die reden seit über zwei
jahren darüber dass wir die menschen zum
impfen an ihren wollen wir wissen gar
nicht wer geimpft ist und deshalb ist
die klare forderung diesem antrag ein in
frigges damit wir erstmal die
datengrundlage haben und genau diese die
da bekämpfen zu können zweiter punkt es
bringt doch nichts jetzt zu sagen alle
sollen sich impfen lassen natürlich
helfen uns impfungen jeder kann
individuell entscheiden
im funktionen dazu dass ich keine
schweren verläufe habe aber die impfung
mit den jetzigen impfstoffen gibt uns
doch nicht die gewähr dafür dass wir im
herbst für eine variante die wir
momentan überhaupt noch nicht kennen mit
einem impfstoff den wir momentan
überhaupt noch nicht haben dass wir
damit aus dieser dauerschleife
herauskommt und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen geht es um
differenzierung und genau das tut unser
antrag denn unser antrag
nimmt auch die notwendige
differenzierung vor liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen die sagen erstens wir
brauchen die impf infrastruktur die wird
vorgehalten wenn sich die lage
verschlechtert heißt dass wir können es
schnell wieder hochfahren gleichzeitig
sagen die aber auch wir müssen
wissenschaftlich evaluiert
wissenschaftlich determiniert sagen
können welche gruppen betrifft es wer
hat ein hohes risiko können wir diese
gruppen damit schützen haben die ein
geeignetes mittel und als letzten punkt
dieses mittel muss verhältnismäßig sein
und die verhältnismäßigkeit ist nur dann
gegeben wenn wir damit auch das was wir
erreichen wollen nämlich schutz der
verfolgung erreichen können und weshalb
ich komme zum schluss frau präsidentin
stimmen sie unserem vorsorge mechanismus
zu das ist der einzige sinnvolle
kompromisse und gangbare weg hätten sie
drei der wie der minister immer ab mit
parteipolitik bei der parteipolitik ist
dass wir als opposition vorschläge
unterbreiten oder die regierung
kritisieren da finde ich da ist ja so
dass ich finde ich das als kompliment
sie können das gerne als kompliment
erfinden aber nicht meine ermahnung das
nehme ich nicht an weil wir haben ja
alle nur sehr gute zeiten in dieser
debatte und deswegen kann ich nicht
jetzt locker sagen sie dürfen 50 minuten
40 sekunden minuten überziehen dank für
die konstruktive hinter heißt ich denke
am ende bank am ende mit mal gerede
danke für die aufmerksamkeit an
ausgesuchten hand sorgen jetzt hat
[Applaus]
für die afg fraktion der kollege martin
sichert das wort
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
weil meine tochter kontakt mit einem
positiv getesteten kind hatte forderte
mich das gesundheitsamt auf ich solle
zitat möglichst innerhalb des haushalts
getrennte räume nutzen und gemeinsame
mahlzeiten vermeiden bei einer
zweijährigen dass meine damen und herren
ist staatliche aufforderung zur
kindesmisshandlung
so weit so weit konnte es nur kommen
weil man die maßnahmen von der realität
von daten fakten und echtem
gesundheitsschutz völlig entkoppelt hat
laut daten der betriebskrankenkassen gab
es bis august mehr
arbeitsunfähigkeitstage wegen
impfnebenwirkungen als nach einem
positiven corona test mehr
arbeitsunfähigkeit wegen
impfnebenwirkungen als nach positiven
corona test diese impfung meine damen
und herren ist eindeutig nicht sicher
der kölner karneval bei 2g plus war ein
super sprayer event das beweist dass die
impfung keinen ausreichenden fremd
schutz bietet auch der eigenschutz
funktioniert nicht es sind mehr corona
intensivpatienten gemustert als
ungeimpft eine impfpflicht ohne
ausreichende sicherheit oder wirksamkeit
des impfstoffes ist nur eines eindeutig
verfassungswidrig
auch gesundheitspolitisch gibt es keine
grundlage für eine impfpflicht in den
letzten beiden jahren waren jeweils
zweieinhalb millionen patienten weniger
in den krankenhäusern als 2009 10 auch
auf den intensivstationen liegen seit
monaten deutlich weniger menschen als im
durchschnitt 18 1091 waren es letzten
sonntag das ist der niedrigste jemals
gemessene wert an intensiv patienten
eine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
drohte nie zu jedem zeitpunkt in den
letzten zwei jahren waren tausende
intensivbetten verfügbar
was aber fehlt sind wichtige studien zur
impfung man gibt erbgut des virus in den
menschlichen körper und weiß bis heute
nicht was danach passiert wie verhält
sich der impfstoff genau im körper wie
verteilt er sich in welchen organen
welche auswirkungen hat die m rna noch
neben das bike proteinproduktion welche
schäden können durch das bike protein
passieren fragen über fragen die niemand
beantworten kann weil das nicht
ausreichend erforscht ist meine damen
und herren
realsatire ist wenn alle bundestags
präsidentin geimpft sind vier von sechs
an corona erkrankt sind und der
bundestag trotz dieser offensichtlichen
unwirksamkeit über eine impfpflicht
diskutiert
die anderen länder haben begriffen dass
maßnahmen mehr schaden als nutzen nein
zu impfpflicht nein zur corona willkür
beenden wir es endlich auch in
deutschland vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die von kubicki und andere hat der
russen ist es gut
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
uns eint das ziel die pandemie zu
bewältigen und die überlassung des
gesundheitswesens abzuwenden ein guter
immunstatus trägt wesentlich dazu bei
uneins sind wir uns ob eine impfpflicht
das geeignete instrumente ist diese
differenz zieht sich durch die
gesellschaft durch familien wissenschaft
und parteien selten wurde so emotional
diskutiert die menschen gerade die
jungen sehnen sich nach normalität und
das ist nur verständlich
und haben viele menschen auch zahlreiche
gedichte geschrieben dass sie eine
impfentscheidung selbst treffen wollen
viele haben ängste einige berichten von
starken impfreaktionen dem
paul-ehrlich-institut liegen nur
gemeldeten nebenwirkungen und im schäden
vor wie hoch die dunkelziffer ist wissen
wir nicht wir sollten die fälle
systematisch erfassen damit nehmen wir
die bedenken ernst und das schafft auch
vertrauen
ob es frauen hat die lage grundlegend
verändert wir wissen nicht welchen
schutz die impfung bei neuen varianten
bietet und eine sterile immunität so
führen die biologen kann mit einer
impfpflicht nicht erreicht werden wenn
ich mir aber die reden hier anhören
möchte ich dass genau diese erwartung
geweckt wird und das führt auch zu
weiteren frust nach heutigem stand geht
es bei der impfung er um den eigen als
um den fremdschutz und daher ist eine
impfpflicht noch schwieriger zu
rechtfertigen und die aufgabe die
aufgabe des staates ist nicht die
menschen vor sich selbst zu schützen
sondern das gesundheitssystem am laufen
zu halten
wir brauchen niedrigschwellige
beratungsangebote mehr forschung eine
bessere datenlage und ein glück sammer
anhaltender immunstatus nach einer
durchgemachten infektion sollte
angesichts des erheblichen
grundrechtseingriff
anerkannten kollegen bei der
größten fragen
beantworten bei der beurteilung der uni
immunität der bevölkerung sollte auch
die zahl der durch eine infektion
immunisierten menschen berücksichtigt
werden hieß es die rede zu rauchen
weniger alarmismus und mehr sachlichkeit
neue erkenntnisse führenden der
wissenschaft dazu position zu revidieren
daran sollten wir uns in der politik ein
beispiel bienen seien
ich weiß dass die redezeiten kurz sind
das wird immer dazu dass es dann immer
sozusagen sondern ein drittel länger ist
wenn man eine halbe minute über zieht
das geht natürlich nicht ich bin total
nicht so streng aber streng
dr paula potter hat jetzt das wort für
die gruppe janitschek ullmann und andere
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin und
erstmal herzlichen dank dass sie mit
petra pau hier diese woche diesen
wahnsinns job machen allein zu zweit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die pflicht uns offensichtlich nicht
mehr das wichtigste thema in diesem haus
das sieht man auch hier greifen aber ich
glaube sie kann unglaublich wichtiger
baustein sein und hinweisgeber bei der
frage ob wir die vielen verschiedenen
krisen die wir jetzt gerade alle
gemeinsam lösen müssen ob wir dieser
verantwortung als dieses haus wirklich
gerecht werden und ich verstehe sehr gut
dass viele bei dieser frage keinen
kompromiss machen wollen aber gerade vor
dem hintergrund der vielen krisen die
wir jetzt alle auf einmal bewältigen
müssen dürfen kompromisse nicht
schlechtgeredet werden und ich verstehe
jeden der gruppe über 18 ich verstehe
jeden der das gefühl hat hier könnte
sich eventuell am ende nicht die beste
variante durchsetzen aber ich möchte
darum bitten dann trotzdem nicht alles
beiseite zu wischen was man auch mit
einer teillösung noch erreichen kann
gerade für die pflege jeder der sich
immer aufgeregt hat darüber dass für die
pflege nur vom balkon geklatscht wurde
er kann jetzt hier über seinen eigenen
schatten springen und zumindest
erreichen dass die überlassung des
gesundheitswesens und damit die
überlastung der vielen menschen die in
diesen gesundheitswesen arbeiten und hat
jeden monat kolleginnen und kollegen
verlieren dass zumindest der vorgebeugt
wird
und ich glaube am ende wird sich auch
hier entscheiden ob wir dieser
verantwortung gerecht werden die jetzt
auf unseren schultern liegt und ich habe
heute nicht in jeder minute in diesem
haus das gefühl gehabt dass dieser
bundestag sich seiner verantwortung
bewusst ist aber wenn wir gut sind wenn
wir richtig gut sind dann werden wir
auch am ende dieses prozesses zeigen
dass auch wenn es schwierig ist das auch
wenn es kompliziert ist auch wenn viele
menschen gerade auch jüngere menschen
bei uns sehr mit sich ringen und die
aktuell auf dem tisch liegenden
kompromisslösung nicht gut finden dass
wir es trotzdem schaffen am ende ich
hier eine mehrheit dafür zu haben die
lebensbedingungen in diesem land und die
möglichkeit für alle patienten gerade
auch die vielen menschen die jetzt
gerade neu zu uns kommt im herbst in
einem gut funktionierenden
gesundheitssystems zu erhalten vielen
dank
[Applaus]
sehen
kathrin winkler spricht jetzt für die
gruppe während und anbringen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren was ist unsere aufgabe
als politik ich bin aus tiefsten herzen
liberale also lautet meine antwort zu
tun was notwendig ist und zu unterlassen
was nicht unbedingt notwendig
andersherum
politik muss sich wann immer möglich
heraushalten und menschen ihr leben
selbstbestimmt führen lassen gerade
deswegen streite ich für die allgemeine
impfpflicht
es ist richtig
freiheitseinschränkung jetzt zurück zu
fahren und gleichzeitig die
erwartungshaltung zu kommunizieren dass
jeder sofern noch nicht geschehen bis
zum herbst einen vollständigen
impfschutz erwirbt ich möchte nicht nur
dass wir so schnell wie möglich
beschränkungen zurücknehmen können ich
möchte dass wir sie nicht jeden herbst
neu einführen müssen dass wir in zukunft
überhaupt nicht mehr in diese maßnahme
spirale heiraten
freiheit ist nicht nur freiheit
verspritzen freiheit ist auch in schule
und liter zu lernen und zu spielen ist
auch die freiheit gesetzt
weil die schicker und musik besitzer
theaterschauspieler und messebauer ihrem
beruf nachgehen zu können
freiheit bedeutet sich bei indikation
einer krankenhausbehandlung unterziehen
zu können und nicht auf das abflachende
aktuellen corona welle warten zu müssen
freiheit ist auch im alter mit der
familie im pflegeheim geburtstag feiern
zu dürfen meine damen und herren auf dem
rücken all dieser menschen wird die viel
zu geringe impfquote in deutschland
ausgetragen all diesen menschen
gegenüber besteht auch eine
schutzpflicht des staates
grundrechte café rechte gegenüber den
start sie sollen den staat zwingen sich
zu rechtfertigen wenn er in die von
ihnen geschützten rechtsgüter eingreift
sie sollen ihn nicht zur untätigkeit
verdammt um bei einer aktuellen quelle
kurzfristig eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems entgegenzuwirken
haben wir inzwischen ein instrumentarium
entwickelt
aber die anwendung dieser instrumente in
der lässt massive kollateralschäden
lassen sie uns das so gut es geht vom
haydn gehen wir mit einer umfassenden
pflichtigen impfkampagne einen anderen
weg denken wir weiter denn auch das
virus mutiert weiter wir haben ein
konzept vorgelegt das noch einmal auf
umfassende informationen setzt am ende
aber auch eine klare erwartung
kommuniziert wir schlagen eine umsetzung
vor die für die allermeisten ganz
unkompliziert erfüllbar ist mit einem
einfachen upload oder einem gang in die
apotheke machen wir das und ja es gibt
das risiko dass wir die impfpflicht am
ende nicht gebraucht haben werden
dagegen abzuwägen ist das risiko dass
wir uns alle und unsere kinder erneut
stark zurücknehmen müssen für mich ist
das ergebnis der abwägung klar vielen
dank
[Applaus]
andreas spricht jetzt für die cdu csu
fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
mir fällt es immer noch schwer an dieser
stelle zur impfung zu sprechen ich stehe
immer noch unter den eindrücken der rede
des ukrainischen präsidenten und ich
will an dieser stelle nur eines sagen
bevor ich zum eigentlichen thema
gekommen es wäre anständig gewesen es
wäre da wäre angemessen gewesen es wäre
erforderlich gewesen dass die fraktionen
in diesem bundestag die möglichkeit
gehabt hätten unmittelbar auf diese rede
zu antworten und ihre solidarität zu
bekunden und das war keine glanzstunde
was dieses parlament hier heute morgen
abgeleistet hat
wir beraten in dieser woche zu dem
wichtigen thema der pandemie zwei
vorhaben
die liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der ampel wollen morgen in der zweiten
lesung
die masken pflicht im rahmen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
quasi abschaffen die verpflichtende
masken pflicht im öffentlichen raum zu
einer zeit in der die inzidenz
2651 liegt zu einer zeit in der die
korona fälle täglich bei knapp 300.000
liegen und die todesfälle über 200
betragen sie wollen die masken pflicht
abschaffen und sie tun das morgen mit
ihrer mehrheit wir werden ausdrücklich
nicht zustimmen die maske schützt direkt
und unmittelbar denjenigen der sie trägt
und das gegenüber die masken pflicht ist
kein großer eingriff in die grundrechte
die massen pflicht ist das mildeste und
geeignetste mittel um der jetzigen
situation schutz vor dem corona virus zu
bieten gerade auch wohlhabenden personen
ich will ihnen sagen wenn sie eine
person mit einer immunschwäche sind weil
sie eine schwere erkrankung haben und
sie müssen einkaufen gehen sie müssen
nicht ins restaurant gehen aber sie
müssen einkaufen gehen und sie versuchen
täglich zu verhindern dass sie sich
anstecken dann sind sie demnächst
schutzlos sie können selber freiwillig
noch eine maske tragen aber ob das
gegenüber eine maske trägt bleibt ihrem
gegenüber freiwillig überlassen und ich
finde dass zum jetzigen zeitpunkt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
verantwortungslos natürlich muss man
auch über die reduzierung der masken
pflicht sprechen aber doch bitte zu
einem zeitpunkt der angemessen und
richtig ist ich kann das beim besten
willen nicht nachvollziehen was sie sich
hier überlegt haben und die gleichen
kolleginnen und kollegen die morgen der
abschaffung der masken pflicht der
verpflichtenden masse nicht zustimmen
werden sprechen sich hier in großen
teilen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt für eine
sofortige impfpflicht aus es tut mir
wirklich leid es ist wirklich chaos was
bei ihm in der gesundheitspolitik
herrscht
wir wissen bei der info dass sie für den
herbst als vorbereitung wichtig ist das
heißt unser antrag die ganz klar vor die
impfkampagne weiterzufahren wir wollen
auch vorbereitet sein für den herbst
deswegen sagen mit unserem in vorsorge
antrag auch ganz klar bitte führen sie
endlich des zwingend notwendige register
ein wir brauchen den überblick über den
status wir müssen personen gezielt
ansprechen können auch was booster
impfungen angeht wir müssen die
ungeimpften noch mal gezielt ansprechen
können und wir müssen mit einer validen
daten lage endlich die pandemie
vernünftig steuern können in dieser lage
jetzt und zum dritten
haben wir mit unserem antrag ein
mechanismus vorgesehen der dann wenn es
nötig und erforderlich ist einen
stufenweisen im mechanismus in gang
setzt und dafür müssen sie jetzt
sozusagen in einem monitoring die die
infektionszahlen der über 60-jährigen
beachten den erhöhenden die situation
auf den intensivstationen kollegen wenn
wir das tun dann können wir
zielgerichtet agieren und deswegen bitte
ich sie auch unsere figuren vernünftigen
attraktion zu stehen und da auch ein
gutes gesetz zu machen sind richtige
vorsorge für den vertrauten evans was
kommt und ich bitte sie auch morgen
nicht der entkoppeln sie und sie sind zu
zweit über die diese zeit hinaus
gegangen
[Applaus]
das gibt mir gelegenheit noch einmal
darauf hinzuweisen
herr bürgermeister gleich es gibt mir
gelegenheit noch einmal darauf
hinzuweisen die allgemeinverfügung sieht
folgendes vor erstens dass die maske im
saal getragen wird und zwar über der
nase und über dem mund zweitens dass sie
abgenommen werden kann wenn jemand am
redepult oder am saalmikrofon spricht
oder als präsidentin hier oben spricht
drittens nicht abgenommen werden kann
bei zwischenrufen oder gesprächen mit
der nachbarin oder dem nachbarn ich
bitte sie das zu berücksichtigen ich
habe gestern hier schon damit drohen
müssen dass es ordnungsmaßnahmen gibt
und jetzt gebe ich das wort dem kollegen
dr andreas bovenschulte dem
bürgermeister von bremen für die gruppe
während
seine frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren abgeordnete im
land bremen sind ca 90 prozent der
menschen einmal geimpft die zahl der
doppelt geimpft licht etwas darunter und
fast zwei drittel sind auch schon
gebucht hatten und ich muss sagen ich
muss sagen wir sind auch ein bisschen
stolz auf diese zahlen denn sie sind das
ergebnis einer großen
gesamtgesellschaftlichen
kraftanstrengung von politik und
verwaltung von hilfsorganisationen und
heimischer wirtschaft wir haben
leistungsfähige impfzentren aufgebaut
wir sind mit unseren impft trucks in die
quartiere gefahren die haben dezentrale
angebote in unseren bürgerhäusern
gemacht wir haben mehrsprachige
gesundheits fachkräfte in die quartiere
geschickt wo die elf wurden besonders
niedrig sind wir haben geworden wir
haben diskutiert werden auch gestritten
und wir haben es dadurch durch die
ansprache der gesamten bevölkerung warum
geschafft ein richtig gutes im klima im
land zu schaffen mit argumenten ohne
druck und ohne zwang
und trotzdem meine damen und herren
spreche ich mich heute für die
einführung einer allgemeinen pflicht in
deutschland aus eine position übrigens
die ich hier nicht alleine vertreten
sondern stellvertretend für die 16
ministerpräsidenten
und ministerpräsidentin die sich schon
mehrfach
auf ihren konferenzen ganz klar und
eindeutig hinter dieser forderung damit
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
wenn jetzt die impfquote bundesweit
stagniert obwohl ausreichend impfstoff
jederzeit verfügbar sind und wohl es
ausreichend informationen zum impfen in
allen möglichen sprachen gibt dann
stellt sich schon die frage welche
schlüsse müssen wir daraus ziehen eine
erkenntnis aus meiner sicht zentral die
meisten die sich bisher nicht haben im
klassen werden diesen schritt ohne eine
gesetzliche pflicht auch künftig nicht
geben das könnten wir jetzt natürlich
einfach hinnehmen als ausdruck
individueller freiheit betätigung
wirklich klug meine damen und herren
wäre das aber nicht denn die meisten
dieser menschen werden sich über kurz
oder lang infizieren etliche werden
mangels im funk schwer erkrankten müssen
in den krankenhäusern und auf den
intensivstationen behandelt werden und
spätestens dann wenn die kliniken an
ihre belastungsgrenzen stoßen sollten
wäre das wir uns alle ein problem dann
wäre das nicht mehr ausdruck
individueller
freiheitsbewegung sondern ein tiefes
grundlegendes gesellschaftliches problem
dann müssten wir reagieren dann rufen
wir beschränkungen
beim gruppen wieder schließung von
geschäften schulen und kitas dann
drucken wieder kontakt beschränkungen
die ökonomischen nicht zuletzt die
sozialen folgen immer wiederkehrender
beschränkung zyklen sind enorm als
bürgermeister habe ich in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten viele
gespräche mit eltern und schülerinnen
und schülern mit unternehmern mit
vertretern von sportvereinen von kirchen
von verbänden geführt und ich kann ihn
einst versichern die menschen wollen und
können nicht mehr ich kann jedem nur
dringend empfehlen sich einmal mit einer
alleinerziehenden berufstätigen mutter
zu unterhalten und darüber zu sprechen
was monatelange schul und kita
schließung mit ihr gemacht haben meine
damen und herren die familien in
deutschland sind wirklich am limit um es
deshalb
ganz klar und deutlich zu sagen wenn wir
die pandemie ohne impfpflicht hinter uns
lassen können das wäre gut das wäre
schön wenn wir aber nun die wahl haben
zwischen einer ständigen beschränkung
und lockdown gefahr und der impfpflicht
dann sollten wir uns für die impfpflicht
entscheiden
meine damen und herren ich habe es
keinen anlass sagt im kreis der
ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten haben sonst
einmütig hinter der allgemeinen pflicht
versammelt zuletzt vor vier wochen
insbesondere kolleginnen und kollegen
war stets ein großes anliegen eine
entsprechende forderung in dem bka
beschlüsse aufzunehmen deshalb hoffe ich
sehr dass am ende auch herr kollegen der
union einen allgemeinen gesetzlichen
pflicht zustimmen werden herzlichen dank
vielen dank
und auch das für sie zur kenntnis den
wunsch nach zwischen fragen werde ich
hier nicht artikulieren können wenn die
redezeit praktisch schon zu ende ist
deswegen war das jetzt hier
nicht mehr möglich ja vielleicht bin ich
auch so strengen weil wir bis heute
nacht hier zurzeit sitzen aber nehmen
sie es dann als persönliche
betroffenheit das können sie gerne genau
das macht aber nichts jetzt habe ich
nämlich dem kollegen dr gregor gysi das
wort zu geben für die gruppe kubicki und
für eine minute
auch präsidentin meine kürzeste rede in
der geschichte des bundestages ich bin
dreimal geben und genesen bär geht gar
nicht aber ich bin ein strikter gegner
der allgemeinen pflicht beim asam war
ich dafür weil das die krankheit aus
rottete das schafft der impfstoff hier
nicht eigentlich brauchen wir eine
aufklärung 30 pro tag und bremen hat es
ja geschafft auch dank unserer linken
sozialsenatorin
geldbußen sind für mich der falsche weg
und wenn sie die regeln ist die dürfen
nicht umgewandelt werden in haftstrafen
dann werden die anderen die bei denen
umgewandelt wird welchen der geldbußen
vor das bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen
viel spaß wegen der gleichheit gibt es
jetzt den wunsch in einer zwischenfrage
möchten sie das zulassen gegeben
ich weiß dass ich was sie dafür bezahlt
haben
ja herr kollege bitte die zwischenfrage
ist zugelassen ich hoffe dass jetzt
keine marktwirtschaftliche angelehnte
person und frage dass ich den restlichen
noch unterbringen
ja viel deutlicher kollege die sie dass
diese zwischenfrage zu lassen und ich
bin überzeugt dass sie die letzten
sekunden auch noch hinbekommen werden
meine frage an sie konkret ist was ist
ihre lösung die krankheitslast für den
kommenden winter den durchaus
hypothetischer passieren könnte
eigentlich begegnen wollen weil das ist
ja keine lösung wir wollen nicht impfen
oder gewonnen kann im pflicht einführen
wie wollen sie die restliche diese im
pflücke eigentlich schließen die
sich momentan in einer lösung ja ich sag
dir gerade ich sagte gerade das der
30.000 menschen pro tag überzeugen
müssen und ich bin es kann uns gelingen
wenn wir so machen wie es in bremen
gemacht worden ist wenn wir das überall
machen und
außerdem bin ich noch sagen wir haben
jetzt 16 millionen nicht geimpfte mal
angenommen fünf millionen machen dass
nach der pflicht ein bleiben elf
millionen übrig bibel hunderttausende
ordnungsämter brauchen wir dann
eigentlich um das durchzusetzen ein
gesetz dass man nicht durchsetzen kann
darf man auch nicht beschließen
dankeschön
kathrin vogler spricht jetzt zu uns für
die gruppe behrens und andere
[Applaus]
nehmen dann frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen lieber
brieger diese ich schätze dich als
mensch und politiker weil die liegst du
einfach falsch inzwischen dürfte noch in
deutschland fast jeder jemanden kennen
die oder der gerade wegen corvette 19
krank oder in quarantäne
wir haben aktuell eine inzidenz fast
dreimal so hoch wie in vergleichbaren
ländern täglich mehr als 200 tote
zunehmende krankenhauseinweisungen und
auch wieder mehr menschen und zwar vor
allem ungeimpfte auf den
intensivstationen
auch von unseren kolleginnen sind einige
die heute mit diskutieren wollten wegen
koppelt 19 nicht bei uns und ich wünsche
ihnen glaube in ihrer aller namen dass
sie sie dass sie schnell und vor allem
vollständig gewesen
selbstverständlich ist das nicht immer
mehr menschen leiden langfristig und das
schweren folgen selbst wenn die
infektion leicht verlaufen ist die
autorin margaret des stokowski
beschreibt ihre erfahrungen mit long
corvette in ihrer jüngsten spiegel
kolumne kolumne eine kolumne sie
ansonsten einfach mal so leicht
unterschrieb die er jetzt aber alle
kraft und viel zeit abverlangt falls es
sie interessiert ich habe jetzt seit
zwei monaten täglich kopfschmerzen und
bin von jeder kleinigkeit erschöpft ich
habe immer wieder schwächeanfälle für
mehrere stunden und dazu ein übriges
kribbeln null hunger oder appetit mein
gehirn funktioniert nicht richtig und
ich schlafe oft 14 stunden und bin
danach absolut nicht erholt sondern
genauso kaputt wie am tag davor
meine damen und herren von long beach
kann man sich nicht individuell schützen
der beste schutz davor ist eine hohe
impfrate in der bevölkerung leben fasten
abstand und all den maßnahmen die sie
kennt weil geimpfte einfach weniger
ansteckend sind und es gibt auch einen
messbaren zusammenhang zwischen der
impfquote unter sterblichkeit und
dennoch haben wir es nicht überall
geschafft so wie in bremen die
impflücken zu schließen und jeder der
glaubt dass wir das bis zum sommer
schaffen weil er wenn dann die
infektionszahlen sinken und es keine
zweige regel mehr gibt der glaubt auch
noch in die zahnfee es gehört einfach
zur menschlichen natur gefahren die
nicht akut erscheinen zu verdrängen und
und erst dann zu handeln wenn sie
wirklich ein im persönlichen umfeld
auftauchen aber wenn im herbst dieses
jahres die nächste corona welle anrollt
der weiß mit welchem virus dann wird es
zu spät sein wenn wir dann nicht über
lockt sonst kontakt beschränkungen über
oder schulschließungen erleben wollen
dann müssen wir jetzt handeln
und
nein die idee menschen wehr gesetzt zum
impfen zu verpflichten die begeistert
mich überhaupt nicht und ich habe viel
kritik an einer politik die es überhaupt
erst so weit hat kommen lassen aber nach
zwei jahren mit immer wiederholten
freiheitseinschränkung und all ihren
sozialen und gesellschaftlichen
verwüstungen die sie hinterlassen haben
dann halte ich das zumindest für zwar
alle erwachsenen zu verpflichten sich
zum schutz aller vor dieser krankheit
unter weiteren freiheits einschränkungen
zu impfen zu lassen
favoritin haben wir zum 1 beim gesang
geht an dieser stelle an die mitglieder
der unionsfraktion
verweigern sie sich nicht nutzen sie die
uneinigkeit der regierungskoalition in
dieser frage nicht für kurzfristige
parteipolitische regierung zeigen sie
gut sein
der nächste redner ist dr herbert räumen
für die gruppe janitschek und ullmann
und andere und erhält heute hier seine
erste rede
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und haben also wie man
abweichend vom meinem rhedes crypt 1
voraus hätten was ich gestern und
vorgestern und heute an medizinischen
unseren gehört habe das ist hanebüchen
sehr geehrte damen und herren als arzt
für innere medizin der in den letzten 30
jahren in der altmark ambulant und stadt
und stationär praktiziert hat werde ich
zwei dinge in meiner rede deutlich
machen
erstens was hat mich dazu gebracht
diesen 50 am tag mit einzubringen und
zweitens waren glaube ich das ist der
richtige weg ist um aus der aktuellen
situation hinaus zu kommen mir bleibt
der vierzehnter
2021 in besonderer erinnerung an diesem
von vielen menschen in meinem wahlkreis
herbeigesehnten tag habe ich erstmals
mit meinem praxisteam gegen kobe 19 gmt
der dezember davor also der dezember
mit vielen corona schwer kranken und
toten auch unter meinen patienten und
patientinnen war noch sehr präsent und
beeindruckt eine weitere grenzwertige
belastung unseres gesundheitssystems
darf es nicht mehr geben im fall bleibt
das beste mittel
der das bisher nicht begriffen hat
handelt verantwortungslos
wir wissen zuverlässig dass erstens eine
impfung die häufigkeit eines schweren
verlaufs signifikant reduziert zweitens
dass die nebenwirkungen der impfungen
vergleichbar mit denen anderer impfungen
sind und da muss sich der abgeordnete
der grünen weitgehend
widersprechen die hiervon geredet hat
das war wirklich daneben
drittens
das ist eine altersabhängige häufung von
schweren kurs 19 erkrankungen gibt die
insbesondere ab dem fünfzigsten
lebensjahr zunehmend relevant wird das
ist ja auch der grund für unseren antrag
besonders der dritte punkt also die
alters abhängigkeit der komplikationen
führt in der pandemie zu einer starken
belastung unseres gesundheitssystems
daher heißt es bei uns erst beraten erst
noch mal alle beraten dann nimmt herr
kollege
auch bei der ersten rede wenn es dann
sehr viel ist ich erinnere nur daran
dass ihre redezeit um ist ich bin zehn
sekunden gut weiter als auch 15
diese einschätzung die wir haben in
ihrer stellungnahme auch die mitglieder
des deutschen ethikrates
an dem sich unser antrag bei kind
orientiert die wahrung der
verhältnismäßigkeit
verpflichtet uns das mildeste mittel zu
werden
betrachtet man diese aspekte so ist
dieser puppen attacke nur 50 die beste
lösung denn die höhe sind nicht die die
unser gesundheitssystem belasten
jetzt bin ich fertig und ich hoffe dass
wir unseren alltag weitgehend zustimmt
dann
auch ihre erste rede hält heute hier die
kolleginnen emilia müller fest für die
gruppe während und andere
vielen dank kopf präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und die fdp fraktion
als die pandemie begonnen hat war ich 21
jahre alt
wissen sie noch was sie gemacht haben
als die 21 waren
ich habe aus den ich habe innerhalb der
vergangenen zwei jahre aus vorsicht und
aus rücksicht das folgende nicht gemacht
ich war nicht in der uni
ich war nicht im ausland
ich habe kein museum und auch kein
festival besucht ich habe nicht mal eine
person die ich noch nicht kannte geküsst
oder meinen geburtstag gefeiert
ich habe verdammt noch meine ich einmal
im club tanzen feiern und all das was
ich so vermissen es mag ihnen jetzt
vielleicht lächerlich vorkam aber wissen
sie was wirklich lächerlich ist wenn sie
und ihre freundinnen der freiheit sich
einfach hätten impfen lassen als die
meisten von uns so vernünftig waren in
diesen einfachen schritt gegangen
dann werde ich jetzt wieder zeit
denn wählen wir alle wieder frei oder
zumindest so ja um das um was wir lieben
und worauf ich jetzt seit zwei jahren
warten was manche von uns depressiv
macht menschen in die einsamkeit stürzt
und familien in den wahnsinn treibt weil
wir bereit sind unsere freiheit für das
leben anderer menschen zu geben wo ihre
gruppen zu schützen das war und das ist
unsere solidarität
aber
ich fordere jetzt den payback wir haben
nämlich etwas gefunden was uns schützen
kann und deshalb will ich meine freiheit
zurück ich will sie zurück
und ich will sie nicht nur kurzzeitig
zurück weil jetzt einige leute besonders
laut freedom day rufen
und offensichtlich alle erfahrungen mit
diesem virus die wir alle gemeinsam
gemacht haben ignorieren liebe fdp
fraktion nur weil man die pandemie für
beendet erklärt ist sie noch nicht
vorbei
diese ihre individuelle freiheit endet
dort wo meine beginnt wo die kollektive
freiheit viking und ihre persönliche
entscheidung sich nicht impfen zu lassen
beeinflusst mein leben beeinflusst das
leben von millionen von menschen in
dieser bundesrepublik nicht die
impfpflicht ist die zumutung sondern
keine impfpflicht ist die zumutung wie
zentrum für die solidarische mehrheit
ich habe mich nicht um ein
bundestagsmandat beworben und im
bundestag dabei zuzusehen wie meine
generation in klimafragen angst um ihre
zukunft haben muss und parallel dazu in
der pandemie auch noch ihre gegenwart
verliert ihre freunde ihren sport ihre
bildung diese reise ihren spaß am jungen
sein das muss jetzt ein ende haben und
ich sag' das jetzt auch noch einmal ganz
deutlich es muss hier um die impfpflicht
für alle erwachsenen gehen nicht auf
irgend einer willkürlichen altersgrenze
denn alle menschen egal welchen alters
übertragen das virus stärker wenn sie
ungeimpft sind es reicht nicht mehr mit
kosmetischen eingriffen die schweren
verläufe zu drücken wir arbeiten hier an
der herdenimmunität und deswegen nehme
ich sie jetzt in die pflicht lassen sie
sich impfen für die kinder die
jugendlichen für unsere freiheit ich
kämpfe für die allgemeine impfpflicht ab
18 denn impfen darf keine individuelle
entscheidung mehr sein es ist keine
vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin simone bord
hat für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
unsere
bundesgesundheitsminister möchte eine
impfpflicht einführen dabei sind sie
sich als regierungsparteien selbst sehr
uneinig das mittlerweile ganz
verschiedene anträge aus ihren reihen
gibt hier geht das spektrum vom
impfpflicht ab 18 bis impfpflicht ab 50
oder gar keine impfpflicht und hier
sehen wir sehr sehr deutlich dass es
keine klare und strategische ausrichtung
der jetzigen regierungsparteien gibt
und sehr geehrter herr lauterbach sie
werden ja gar nicht müde immer wieder
die hohen intent zahlen ins feld zu
führen um somit die impfpflicht
durchzusetzen aber auch in der
wirtschaft trifft man keine
strategischen entscheidungen nur anhand
einer kennzahl und ich möchte sie daher
bitten hier in zukunft auch den
schweregrad der erkrankung zu
berücksichtigen dieser ist gerade nicht
vorhanden und auch die hospitalisierung
zahlen sind gerade völlig unauffällig
ins identen alleine bilden die
pandemische entwicklung nicht
sachgerecht ab und verzehren das bild
auch in der bevölkerung und führen zu in
akzeptanz
der antrag der cdu csu so dafür dass wir
genau diesen wichtigen zahlen im blick
behalten werden und bei bedarf dann
reagieren können
außerdem ist aufgrund der impfung sowie
der schon erfolgten infektionen der
immunschutz in der bevölkerung weitaus
höher da lässt es auch nicht den
genesenen status einfach mal so zu
verändern kollege lj gestalten sie eine
frage oder bemerkung der kollegin vogel
frau kollegin borchert ich habe einst
bei ihrem antrag beim antrag ihrer
fraktion und auch bei ihrem vortrag
jetzt immer noch nicht verstanden
der cdu csu ist doch auch bewusst sein
dass bis zum erreichen des vollen
impfschutz mindestens drei impfungen mit
jeweils einem abstand von drei bis vier
fünf sechs monaten erforderlich sind und
insofern
insofern frage ich sie ob es wirklich
eine kluge idee ist mit dem einsetzen
einer impfpflicht zu warten bis eine
neue sehr gefährliche möglicherweise
tödliche variante sich gebildet hat und
sich in deutschland verbreitet wie
wollen sie dem denn dann entgegentreten
können
vielen dank für ihre frage aber es hilft
auch nicht wenn wir immer sagen was wäre
wenn
und deshalb denke ich dass die dass
dieses gesetz zur info sowie das einzig
richtige ist weil wenn die uns an den
richtigen fakten orientieren wollen dann
ein handy und ein incident zahlen an der
schwere der erkrankung an den
hospitalisierung taten und da komme ich
gleich noch drauf auf die inhalte auf
einen impf registern und das ist der
einzig richtige weg woher wollen wir dem
wissen jetzt ohne imf register wer wann
und wie oft geimpft ist
wir halten zum jetzigen zeitpunkt eine
impfpflicht unter den aktuellen
gegebenheiten für nicht zielführend
die korona pandemie stellt uns vor
herausforderungen und wir müssen unser
gesundheitssystem flexibel und
reaktionsfähig halten und aus diesem
grund hat die cdu csu fraktion den
antrag auf ein im vorsorge gesetz
gestellt und hier liegen für uns die
zentralen punkte in einem register und
wenn ich höre immer dass gesprochen wird
von einer geringen impfquote dann frage
ich mich wo haben wir diese daten hier
allein es mit einem im register während
die transparenz und hätten eine gute
datengrundlage
die cdu csu möchte eine gute
impfkampagne und bei bedarf natürlich
ein impf mechanismus der greift wenn es
notwendig ist
in den jahren der pandemie haben wir
dazugelernt und dieses wissen müssen wir
jetzt nutzen um uns für die zukunft
aufzustellen und die rahmenbedingungen
der politik verändern sich im zuge der
entwicklung der pandemie ständig aber
sehr geehrter herr minister und auch
herr beck sie blenden die verändernden
rahmenbedingungen für mich komplett aus
und wir fordern hier mehr wissenschaft
mehr flexibilität und weniger starrsinn
vielen dank
[Applaus]
ein kleiner hinweis während das pult
hergerichtet wird ja wir haben hier eine
debatte zu gruppen und fraktions
anträgen und alle haben das recht auch
redebeiträge zu protokoll zu geben ich
bin aber auch gehalten dafür zu sorgen
dass einerseits das fragerecht
stattfinden kann aber nicht die
redebeiträge sich verdoppeln oder
verdreifachen deshalb lasse ich in der
regel oder fraglich in der regel ob eine
frage oder bemerkung zugelassen wird
innerhalb einer rede zwischen einer
minute und drei minuten aber nicht eine
zweite und dritte jeder hat ja die
chance seine beiträge oder
meinungsäußerungen auch noch zum
protokoll zu geben
nun hat führen die
gruppe behrens zu sein seiner ersten
rede im deutschen bundestag der kollege
kw main sowie das wort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der kampf für
alternativen hat mich von der
landesschülervertretung in hessen bis in
den plenarsaal des deutschen bundestages
geführt es gibt immer eine alternative
aber die alternativen zur impfnachweis
pflicht sind schwere verläufe
überlastung der krankenhäuser
patientinnen und patienten die auf
behandlung warten müssen einschränkungen
des öffentlichen und privaten lebens in
den kitas und schulen in den betrieben
in der kultur gastronomie und im sport
und menschen die unnötig sterben werden
ich finde das sind die schlechteren
alternativen
und wenn ich als und wenn ich als anwalt
hinzufügen darf sie sind auch nicht
grundrecht schonender seit zwei jahren
erleben jetzt eine endlos spirale aus
infektionswellen und schutzmaßnahmen das
land ist müde davon eltern die keine
planbarkeit haben pflegekräfte die am
ende sind und nicht mehr können diese
spirale muss enden der freiheits
beschränkende maßnahmen im herbst
verhindern will der muss die impfquote
jetzt erhöhen und nicht erst im herbst
meine damen und herren
zu beginn der pandemie
da war wenig über das virus und das
infektionsgeschehen bekannt aber wie
viele wellen braucht es dennoch um eine
allgemeine im nachweis pflicht zu regeln
und wie viel solidarität wollen sie
dennoch von kindern und jugendlichen von
jungen menschen ab verlangen die sich
seit zwei jahren einschränken um andere
menschen in diesem land zu schützen ich
finde das muss jetzt aufhören meine
damen und herren und ich will meinen
teil ziehe daraus auch konsequenzen für
mein politisches handeln und ich will
hier auch einräumen dass ich meine
haltung gegenüber einer allgemeinen
impfnachweis pflicht geändert habe ich
finde das zeichnet eine demokratische
debatte auch aus denn wir wollen hier
keine glaubenssätze austauschen sondern
argumente auf der basis von fakten und
wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen wenn die sachlage sich
ändern muss auch die schlussfolgerung
eine andere seite und deswegen will ich
drei erkenntnisse nennen erstens dass
eine impfung zuverlässig vor einer
schwerwiegenden erkrankung schützt ist
erwiesen zweitens erwiesen ist dass eine
vorerkrankung nicht denselben schutz vor
wieder ansteckung bietet wie eine
grundimmunisierung
durchimpfung drittens es gibt
mittlerweile varianten von cobit die
sich so schnell ausbreiten dass selbst
junge menschen sich auf den
intensivstationen finden obwohl sie ein
geringeres risiko haben schwerwiegend zu
erkranken und diese fakten gilt es zu
berücksichtigen wenn wir jetzt über das
für und wider einer allgemein endlich
diskutieren und über die ausgestaltung
ich für meinen teil halte den
gesetzesentwurf für die einführung einer
allgemeinen impfnachweis pflicht ab 18
für vorausschauend und richtig vor allem
bin ich davon überzeugt dass er zeitlich
befristet und beschränkt auf drei
impfungen auch verfassungsgemäß ist denn
unser grundgesetz verlangt von einer
staatlichen maßnahme dass sie einen
legitimen zweck verfolgt geeignet
erforderlich und angemessen ist um
dieses ziel zu erreichen über den
legitimen zweck und die geeignetheit zur
zweck erreichen dürfte hier kein
ernsthafter dissenz bestehen sondern die
debatte dreht sich vor allem um die
erforderlichkeit und angemessenheit
eines verpflichtenden impfnachweis unter
sprechen die besseren argumente und
darauf komme ich gleich für den
gesetzesentwurf
manche wände nein keine impfnachweis
pflicht oder eine für teile der
bevölkerung sein
milder schon darüber kann man streiten
aber es ist eben nicht gleich geeignet
um unsere krankenhäuser im herbst und
unsere allgemeine freiheit zu schützen
und deswegen ist der gesetzesentwurf den
ich unterstütze auch erforderlich war
und natürlich greift ein verpflichtender
impfnachweis in die grundrechte der
menschen ein aber grundrechts güter
gelten eben nicht uneingeschränkt
sondern sie sind in ein verhältnis
zueinander zu bringen und deswegen muss
man auch hier feststellen ja jeder hat
das recht sich unvernünftig zu verhalten
aber dieses recht endet wo millionen
andere jahrelang in ihrer freiheit und
lebensweise eingeschränkt werden
zeitlich befristet und so schwenk auf
drei impfungen ist die nachweispflicht
zumutbar deswegen ist der gesetzes erst
im boot auch angemessen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen 6 millionen
menschen sind mittlerweile an cupid
verstorben auch meine tante ich will in
keiner gesellschaft leben in der korona
tote einkalkuliert sind die impf
nachweispflicht 18 weist einen weg aus
der pandemie gehen sie in bitte mit hat
sich dank für die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion hat nun der
kollege dr günter krings das wort
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren auch die heutigen
debatte hat uns eine entscheidung über
das ob das wie einer impfpflicht nicht
wirklich näher gebracht und der
wichtigste grund ist offensichtlich dass
sie noch immer in der tiefe
zerrissenheit bei diesem thema sind
innerhalb der ampel koalition und die
verstecken dass hinter gruppen anträgen
das kann man machen aber es ist eben die
folge aber mit der dramatischen
weltpolitischen lage schwindelt
schwindet endgültig das verständnis für
diesen agent ismus der bundesregierung
in dieser zentralen innenpolitischen
fragen und offensichtlich durchzieht
diese zerrissenheit in ihrer koalition
ja die gesamte corona politik das andere
prominente beispiel die sitzungswoche
ist die novellierung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
die verbände hatten hier für ihre
beteiligung und stellungnahme knapp neun
stunden in der nacht und im text nehmen
sie den ländern fast alle
handlungsmöglichkeiten zur pandemie
bekämpfung und das alles bei extrem
steigenden ansteckungszahlen ein
ministerpräsident der spd wohlgemerkt
sprach davon man werfe hier den
feuerlöscher mitten im brandt weg meine
damen und herren ich
weiß auch nicht ob er schon dankbar sein
sollen dass sie es überhaupt
infektionsschutzgesetz zu einem
regierungsentwurf gebracht haben und
nicht uns auch damit gruppen anträgen
konfrontiert haben meine damen und
herren aber
wie passt das jetzt eigentlich zusammen
wenn die ampel mehrheit die meisten
schutzmaßnahmen schleift und eine große
mehrheit innerhalb der ampel zugleich
eine sofortige im pflicht einführen will
hat den eindruck bei diesen beiden
themen bewegen sich in zwei parallel
universum meine damen und herren
deshalb mein appell jedenfalls war der
impfpflicht wäre es doch gut wenn sie
ausnahmsweise auf die stimme der
vernunft hören und die besagt erster in
der jetzigen omikron welle käme die
einführung einer allgemeinen impfpflicht
schlichtweg zu spät und zweitens dass
die anordnung einer impfpflicht die dann
im herbst gegen ein neue virusvariante
wirken soll zumindest eben heute noch
nicht zu rechtfertigen ist ja impfen ist
der zentrale weg aus der pandemie und
dennoch ist die pflicht zur impfung ein
grundrechtseingriff und er lässt sich
eben nur rechtfertigen mit der
überlastung des gesundheitssystems dass
wir das verhindern wollen dass sich eine
pflicht zur impfung dann nur auf die
jetzt verfügbaren impfstoffe beziehen
kann deren wirkung auf künftiger
varianten wir noch gar nicht kennen
können das führt dazu dass eben die
geeignetheit nicht gegeben ist
verfassungsrechtlich und bei
entscheidungen unter unsicherheit darf
der gesetzgeber auch nicht voreilig
entscheiden sondern muss zunächst die
verfügbaren erkenntnisse
zusammengetragen und sachgerecht
bewährten genau das fordern wir bis
dahin ist eben eine impfpflicht auch
nicht erforderlich im sinne des
verfassungsrechts meine damen und herren
sehr wohl erforderlich ist aber dass
bund länder und kommunen jetzt ihre
hausaufgaben machen und die
vorbereitungen für eine möglicherweise
später notwendige impfpflicht treffen
das reicht von der stärkung der
infrastruktur
bis hin zum aufbau eines nationalen im
free kisters was wir jetzt brauchen ist
also keine impfpflicht auf vorrat
sondern ein vorsorge gesetz meine damen
und herren
und auch das kann ich nicht ersparen
bleibt die vorlage eines solchen
gesetzes oder desgleichen gesetzentwurf
ist natürlich die ureigenste aufgabe der
bundesregierung dafür gibt es sie meine
damen und herren
in einer zentralen frage
innerhalb der größten krise der
nachkriegszeit in politischer hinsicht
muss die bundesregierung sich endlich
ihrer verantwortung stellen weil
darunter
und sie wäre klug beraten wenn sie dabei
unserem zwei stufen modell folgt aus
sachlichen und verfassungsrechtlichen
gründen aber auch weil es der einzig
realistische weg ist der uns die
sinnvolle option nicht mehr und nicht
weniger die sinnvolle option für eine
impfpflicht erhält ich fordere daher die
regierung auf legen sie einen
regierungsentwurf für im vorsorge gesetz
zügig vor und die probleme mit der
bisherigen berufsbezogenen impfpflicht
das rudern in österreich das zeigt doch
es reicht doch nicht einfach eine
impfpflicht anzuordnen wenn dann muss
sie auch gut vorbereitet sein mal damen
und herren vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin katrin göring
eckardt für die gruppe b
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegin frau
präsidentin lieberherr krieges ich meine
sie zweifeln hier daran dass das
parlament wir als parlament nicht
selbstbewusst genug ist gemeinsam eine
entscheidung in einer so wichtigen frage
zu treffen das verstehe ich nicht
zweiter darauf den ich kenne
wir haben derzeit zwei jahren kann nicht
zwei jahre lang hat die ampel koalition
hier miteinander regiert am anfang der
pandemie haben wir als bündnis 90 die
grünen auch andere fraktionen immer
wieder gesagt ja wir machen das hier im
parlament gemeinsam gestützt in einem
kurs den wir gemeinsam entwickelt haben
unabhängig davon welcher fraktionen oder
welcher partei sie angehören in dieser
frage bleibt und ist das zentral dass
wir hier als parlament gemeinsam in
einem vernünftigen kompromiss eine gute
lösung finden das sage ich bevor ich
begründet warum ich würde ihn vielleicht
auf 18
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dass kollegen krings es soll sein obwohl
ich weiß dass ich selbst
vielen dank frau kollegin da sie mich
angesprochen haben wollte ich gerne
darauf auch mit einer frage wer sie
haben kritisiert dass ich kritisiere
dass es keinen regierungsentwurf gibt
sind sie bereit zur kenntnis zu nehmen
dass ich sehr wohl der auffassung mit
ihnen bin dass nur diese entscheidung im
pflicht ja nein oder wie oder welchem
modell natürlich nur hier im bundestag
von uns als abgetreten ist das aber die
regierung in der pflicht steht in dieser
zentralen frage ein regierungsentwurf zu
machen und erlauben sie mir zugleich
dass ich daran erinnere dass wir bei dem
thema in einer berufsbezogene
impfpflicht auch keine gruppenanträge
haben und damit verbinde ich die frage
sind sie der auffassung dass
krankenpfleger ärztinnen und ärzte dass
deren grundrechte weniger relevant sind
das also da ein regierungsentwurf geht
und ansonsten wie aber gruppenanträge
machen müssen aus gründen der
sensibilität der grundrecht sensibilität
worin liegt der unterschied
übrigens ich beginne mit dem mit dem
zweiten 3 mich das auch sehr und reifen
nämlich die einrichtungs bezogene
impfpflicht und dass viele der menschen
die dort arbeiten das gefühl haben wieso
wir und nicht alle anderen mich bringt
das dazu dass ich die einrichtungs
bezogen im pflicht da habe ich auch
meine meinung geändert in den letzten
wochen monaten dass die einrichtungs
bezogen endlich der erste schritt ist zu
einer allgemeinen endlich darum geht es
und so ihrer zweiten frage herr krings
man kann jetzt auch noch weiter ich weiß
nicht wie lange wochen lang über das
verfahren wegen mir wäre wichtig dass
wir über die sache reden und eine
entscheidung treffen das ist
und deswegen sagen ich habe meine
meinung geändert ich dachte es geht
freiwillig und es geht mit niedrigeren
quoten das war ja bei anderen varianten
auf der fall das ist jetzt nicht mehr so
die welt hat sich dramatisch verändert
aber eins ist geblieben nämlich corona
das virus ist mitnichten verschwunden im
gegenteil die infektionszahlen sind so
hoch wie nie kein tag vergeht an dem
sich eine tochter partnerin partner
arbeitskollegin gute freundin davon
berichtet dass es jetzt zwei striche
sind auf dem schnelltest ko-runde trifft
familien die schulen krankenhäuser die
wirtschaft und ja auch unser parlament
und insbesondere im sinne der kinder
müssen wir jetzt endlich dafür sorgen
dass wir diese pandemie dieses auf und
ab dieses hin und her dieses mal noch
tausendmal freiheit dieses mal maßnahmen
und mal keine mehr endlich beenden und
wir haben dieses eine scharfe schwert
noch in der hand dieses eine scharfe
schwert ist die allgemeine impfpflicht
und ich rufe sie auf mit uns dafür zu
sorgen dass wir in diesem land die
freiheit zurückgewinnen denn genau darum
ich will
ich will das nein es geht nicht um
freiheit durch zwang sondern es geht
darum dass eine minderheit nicht
diktieren kann wie eine mehrheit in
diesem land lebt und wir haben wir haben
wirklich alles daran gesetzt dass das
impfen freiwillig passieren kann und
jeder wird sagen manche kampagne hätte
besser und schicke und ich weiß nicht
was sein können aber inzwischen bald
wieder und jeder das impfen schützt und
dass jede und jeder weiß ich habe eine
verantwortung kann sie wahrnehmen oder
nicht und für diejenigen die sie bisher
nicht wahrgenommen haben da gibt es
welche die haben ernsthafte bedenken
sorgen manche können es übrigens nicht
manche können es nicht und es gibt
menschen die in diesem land seit zwei
jahren grau politur gehen können auch
für die müssen wir sagt im allgemeinen
infos und zuletzt meine damen und herren
sind ich sagen es gibt ja einige
besonders nahe stehende denen die
allgemeine impfpflicht das impfen
überhaupt immer ein riesen problem war
für die wird es jetzt ein bisschen
einfacher da gibt es nämlich eine
anweisung und dann muss man das machen
und auch damit glaube ich sind wir ganz
gut aufgehoben ich bin für die
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 für alle
erwachsenen das ist der weg und gerne
reden wir über alle anderen
verfassungsgemäßen varianten damit wir
hier gemeinsam zu einer guten
entscheidung komme herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
das wort wird der abgeordnete mathias
helferich ja vielen dank frau
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren jüngst attestierte der
bundesgesundheitsminister dr karl
lauterbach dem russischen
staatspräsidenten per ferndiagnose eine
narzisstische persönlichkeitsstörung
da ich mir eine ähnliche
psychoanalytische fachkompetenz wie der
bundesgesundheitsminister zutraue
erlaube ich mir nun mal eine
ferndiagnose das münchhausen by proxy
syndrom ist eine sonderform der
artifiziellen störung war der physisch
gesunde personen bei einem anderen
menschen häufig dem eigenen kind
krankheiten vortäuschen oder bewusst
herbeiführen um anschließend eine
medizinische behandlung zu verlangen der
täter macht das opfer krank um dadurch
anerkennung und aufmerksamkeit zu
erlangen auch wenn keine gefährdung für
das opfer durch eine krankheit besteht
treibt es der täter in zahlreiche
medizinische behandlung erkennen sie das
krankheitsbild und möglicherweise den
erkrankten herr dr lauterbach obwohl
inzwischen zahlreiche echte experten
eine allgemeine impfpflicht ablehnen
wird der bundesgesundheitsminister samt
seiner jünger nicht müde diese immer und
immer wieder lautstark zu fordern
gewichtige stimmen wie die von den
professoren cullen strikt kekulé oder
störe die eine allgemeine impfpflicht
gegen das koma virus sowohl medizinisch
als auch juristisch ablehnen werden
ignoriert weil es ihnen ja längst gar
nicht mehr um gesundheitspolitik in
diesem land geht sie wissen dass sie und
ihre warnung ihr wirken als mächtige
dressur elite mit dem auftauchen von
omikron beendet sind omikron macht das
virus schwach omikron macht aber auch
sie schwach und nach zwei jahren der
angst politik haben sie angst angst vor
dem bedeutungsverlust sie haben nun eine
chance sich an einen heilungsprozess in
unserem land unserer verletzten
gesellschaft zu beteiligen indem sie die
menschen endlich in ruhe lassen und
ihnen ihre freiheit vollumfänglich
zurück geben stimmen sie daher gegen
jede form des im zwangs und beenden sie
die herrschaft des münchhausen
stellvertreter syndrom es in der
bundesdeutschen
gesundheitspolitik vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege dr karl
lauterbach für die gruppe behrens
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt haben wir
eine lange und aus meiner sicht gute
debatte gehabt es gab ein paar tiefpunkt
es gab auch sehr gute beiträge wo stehen
wir jetzt na ja wir müssen uns vor augen
führen das hat sich nicht viel verändert
wir haben die fünf szenarien vor uns die
im herbst kommen können was christian
drosten beschrieben hat in seiner
ausarbeitung auch für mitglieder des
bundestags dass wir im herbst vielleicht
möglicherweise wieder eine mikrowelle
bekommen dass wir vielleicht eine data
varianten
welle bekommen weil derzeit die
impfquote in afrika nur 14 prozent ist
und dort sehr viel dass ich wieder
ausbreitet wir können drohe weiter
entfernte variante bekommen wir können
eine data
kombinations variante bekommen und was
sehr gefährlich wäre und nicht
unwahrscheinlich ist dass sich um mit
kunden weiterentwickelt und einfach
tiefer in die lunge eindringt mal das
sind nur ganz wenige mutationen die das
derzeit verhindern die können jederzeit
verloren
wir schnappen sie eine frage oder
bemerkung des abgeordneten brandner nein
auf keinen fall die
die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir eine dieser
varianten sehen geht an fast 100 prozent
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir im
herbst keine schwierigkeiten haben die
krone pandemie zu bekämpfen liegt bei
fast null prozent
das ist fast so wahrscheinlich aus dass
wir gar keinen herbst bekämen daher wir
müssen uns vorbereiten was wird also im
herbst auf uns zukommen im herbst werden
wir erneut die frage stellen wird unser
gesundheitssystem überlastet sein was
können wir tun um dieser überlastung
begegnet zu begegnen was müssen wir
schließen wie gehen wir mit den
geschäften um was können wir unseren
kindern in not zugute
es sind die pflegekräfte da die wir
benötigen wir können ja nicht die vielen
ungeimpften die dank behandlung
benötigen sie auch bekommen werden den
können wir nicht sagen ihr hättet euch
ja impfen lassen können wir behandeln
uns nicht wir sind eine zivilisierte
gesellschaft das heißt wir werden diese
menschen die zum teil selbst schuld hin
zum grössten 1000 gast wir werden sie
behandeln müssen und dann wird erneut
das ganze land in der geiselhaft dieser
gruppe von menschen sein die sich
einfach gegen die wissenschaftliche
evidenz der weltweiten forschung der
weltweiten behandlungs forscher im
forscher durchsetzen die im prinzip noch
stolz darauf sind dass das land auf sie
wartet ob sie sich impfen lassen oder
nicht das können wir uns aus meiner
sicht nicht mehr lassen wir müssen
einmal rücksicht mehr noch die kinder
wir müssen muss ich dem auch die
pflegekräfte wir müssen nützlich auch
neben auf diejenigen lohnen ihre
existenz jetzt geht es darum dass mal
denjenigen die regeln beachten dass all
die zeit nicht getan haben da kann man
durch die frage stellen wirken die
impfungen überhaupt oder nicht das
wissen wir doch wir wissen dass all die
varianten die wir nicht gerade
aufgezogen gezählt habe all diese
varianten sind genetisch zu weit über 90
prozent identisch teil wirken noch alle
impfstoffe die zwei jahre alten wo hahn
impfstoffe verhindern nach wie vor
schwere krankheit und tod natürlich
verhindern sie nicht in jedem fall die
ansteckung kolleg haben das problem der
ansteckung ist ja nicht das hauptproblem
wenn wir nicht schwer krank werden oder
sterben es geht auch hier darum schwere
krankheit und tod zu verhindern und
dafür haben wir sie müssen ja einsetzen
und ich komme auf die vorschläge des
gegenübers ich ja gesagt mcqueen hatte
fast ganz klar darauf hingewiesen es
stimmt die impfpflicht kommt zu spät für
die omnicom müller das ist wichtig aber
ihr eigener vorschlag der würde doch
dafür sorgen dass die impfpflicht für
jede weitere wenn er die noch von zu
stellen und ihr vorschlag ist doch der
vorschlag dass wir ehrlich gesagt
wichtige zeit verlieren wir kommen nicht
weiter und ich noch eine letzte frage
gestattet er die fragen oder bemerkungen
der kollegin vogler das würde ich machen
ja ich würde sagen die eine zugelassene
von der präsidentin erlaubt dazwischen
frage gut eingeteilt vielen dank herr
kollege laut aber
mir ist ein bisschen auf wir sind ja
gemeinsam unterwegs für dieses thema im
pflicht ab 18 aber mir ist schon ein
bisschen aufgestoßen das sind das so
sehr individualisieren müssten wenn ich
auch ein bisschen demütiger darauf
gucken was die politik in diesen letzten
zwei jahren falsch gemacht hat
unterlassen hat nicht hinreichend auf
den weg gebracht hat um den menschen das
vertrauen zu geben dass diese empfehlung
die wir ihnen geben und das wird so wir
sie auffordern dass sie sich bitte bitte
alle drei mal impfen lassen sollen das
auch wirklich umzusetzen müssen also mir
widerstrebt es einfach darauf diese
diese individualisierte schuldzuweisung
zu machen ich glaube wir haben sie auch
mit gesellschaftlichen prozessen zu tun
und wir müssen nach der pandemie oder
nach dem was wir jetzt alles
entscheidend dringend darüber reden
unser gesundheitswesen solidarischer und
gerechter aufzustellen damit die
menschen auch wieder mehr vertrauen
haben
ja für jeden tag vor dass sie haben
recht schulz zulassungen sind fehl am
platz aber
verantwortungs zuweisungen sind richtig
und die ungeimpften tragen derzeit die
verantwortung dafür dass wir nicht
weiterkommen und das muss man sagen
dürfen das ist auch nicht und im übrigen
wir müssen noch nach vorne blicken
natürlich sind auch fehler gemacht
worden natürlich sind auch fehler
gemacht worden aber wo stehen wir denn
jetzt wir sind jetzt zum ersten mal 20
22 ist das erste jahr wo wir tatsächlich
die pandemie für deutschland leider
nicht weltweit aber wir können die
pandemie für deutschland zum ersten mal
beenden mit der impfung mit dem pflicht
lassen wir uns auch diese gelegenheit
ergreifen wir haben sie jetzt
wenn
wenn wenn
es uns gelingt eine impfquote zu
erreichen die bei den über 60 jährigen
deutlich höher ist als 90 prozent und im
rest der bevölkerung so hoch dass die
wellen sich nicht mehr richtig
ausbreiten können dann können wir vor
einschränkungen im herbst nicht müssen
wir nicht angst haben dann kommen wir
durch dann müssen wenn ich erneut in
dieser endlosschleife zurück diese
gelegenheit haben wir heute und ich
appelliere an alle demokratischen
parteien bitte erlauben sie hier ihren
abgeordneten gewissensentscheidung ich
weiß dass überall in allen parteien
fehle es so sehen wir haben diese
gelegenheit daher werden wir hier über
eine ganz wichtige entscheidung treffen
wir stehen im herbst an der gleichen
stelle wie jetzt wenn wir diese
einmalige chance nicht gemeinsam
ergreifen
[Applaus]
bevor ich die aussprache schließe bitte
ich darum so war sowohl bei verbalen
äußerungen als auch bei nonverbal
meinungsäußerung sich einer
parlamentarischen ausdrucksweise zu
befleißigen ich will jetzt nicht
beschreiben was ich von hier vororte
alles sehen musste und hören musste ich
schließe die aussprache
interfraktionell wird überweisung der
vorlagen auf den drucksachen
978 und 516 an die in der tagesordnung
aufgeführten ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungs vorschläge
das ist nicht der fall dann verfahren
wir wie vorgeschlagen
ein kleiner hinweis den meine kollegin
katrin göring eckardt heute früh auch
schon gegeben hat und gestern zum beginn
unserer beratung sie wissen dass sie bis
morgen nachmittag mit der kollegin
göring eckardt und mir hier vorlieb
nehmen müssen
daraus folgt dass wir natürlich wenn
fragen oder bemerkungen angemeldet
werden die redner befragen ob sie diese
zu lassen wir lassen prinzipiell aber
keine kurzintervention nach den reden zu
es sei denn es ist durch die
geschäftsordnung geboten weil jemand
persönlich in irgendeiner weise
angegriffen wurde das zum weiteren
fortgang
unsere gemeinsame arbeit ich rufe auf
den tagesordnungspunkt 7 beratung des
antrags der fraktionen der cdu/csu mit
dem titel für eine sichere bezahlbare
und souveränen energieversorgung über
den antrag werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten geschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache das wort hat
der kollege jens spahn für die cdu csu
fraktion
[Applaus]